[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 según encuestas
casi 60% de la población en España
estaría a favor de regular la gestación
por sustitución que sin embargo es
considerada una violación de los
derechos humanos y no Es legal en España
por ello Es que decenas de familias
españolas acuden a mujeres en otros
países para poder tener hijos uno de
esos países es Ucrania antes de la
invasión unos 2500 bebés nacían al año a
través de este método por lo que fue
apodada el útero de Europa pero con el
estallido de la guerra la vida de estas
mujeres cambió nuestra corresponsal
Marina Colorado habló con ellas y nos
mostró una de las perspectivas
no quiere no quieren chupete ninguno
convertirse en madre es el deseo de
muchas mujeres pero el camino para
hacerlo no siempre resulta el mismo a
los 32 años apilarle descubrieron un
cáncer de endometrio un diagnóstico
incompatible con gestar a un bebé el
mismo día me dijeron Cuál iba a ser la
operación cómo me iban a operar y Qué
opciones tenía pero al tener una
enfermedad oncológica las adopciones no
prospera que me preguntaron si quería
ser madre evidentemente nosotros
queríamos ser padres y ya nos informaron
de la gestación subrogada este método de
reproducción por el que una mujer gesta
en su útero al bebé de otras personas es
ilegal en España pese a esto cada año
nace en 1500 niños españoles por
gestación subrogada en otros países
Pilar y su esposo optaron por hacer el
proceso en Ucrania un país asequible y
cercano pero sumido en un conflicto
bélico
llevarlo a distancia con la garra ha
sido muy muy duro porque estamos
pendientes las noticias con mil miedos
Todas las semanas cada cosa que pasaba
Yo seguía escribí a Ana estáis todos
bien necesitáis algo porque la relación
con ella ha sido muy muy muy muy buena
el camino de la gestación subrogada
también lo recorrió Eduardo chaperón
pero desde Estados Unidos por qué
Ucrania no admite a parejas del mismo
sexo para este proceso
Eduardo cuestiona la ley Española y la
postura del Ministerio de igualdad que
considera esta práctica como una forma
de violencia contra la mujer Usted cree
que una familia quiere que su hijo sea
consecuencia de la necesidad económica
de una mujer Usted cree que yo me puedo
ir a dormir por la noche mirando los
ojos de mi hijo y siquiera pensar que
está aquí porque he abusado de alguien
esto
la familia que aparece en el vídeo optó
por la gestación subrogada en Ucrania en
2019 Y Tania fue quien lo hizo posible
me di cuenta de que hay personas que no
tienen tanta suerte como yo con los
embarazos por eso traté de ayudar a
alguien de esta manera
esta mujer ucraniana de 38 años vive
refugiada desde el año pasado en España
con su marido y sus tres hijos en un
apartamento que le ha prestado la
familia española para la que dio a luz
nos han apoyado mucho desde el primer
día nada más llegar aquí
Tania ahora espera poder volver a
Ucrania lo antes posible y quizás
reiniciar un segundo proceso de
gestación subrogada para una familia
irlandesa que quedó en pausa por la
guerra
Más allá del deseo de maternar o de
paternar hay que hablar de los vientres
subrogados que son considerados ilegales
en varios países del mundo y además un
dolor de cabeza en otros tantos países
porque se han convertido en un negocio
en el que hay violencia contra la mujer
instrumentalización de los bebés e
incluso tráfico de personas vamos a
conversar sobre lo que implica toda esta
polémica y para ello está en ellas hoy
Ester farnos amoroso ella es doctora en
derecho civil y también profesor en la
universidad pompeu fabra es la autora
Además del artículo la reproducción
asistida ante el tribunal europeo de
Derechos Humanos Muchísimas gracias a
usted por estar en ellas hoy
gracias a vosotras bueno mire esto se ha
hecho hasta el cansancio lo polémico que
es este tema de las maternidades
subrogadas Respecto a los derechos de la
mujer algunas de las críticas tienen que
ver con que la práctica tiene un fuerte
componente por ejemplo de clase Como
sucede también con la prostitución Y es
que si las mujeres gestantes tuvieran
una buena posición económicamente
probablemente nunca ofrecerían su cuerpo
como un producto o como una vasija para
cargar el bebé de otra persona Usted
cree que esto es así
Bueno este es uno de los posibles
argumentos si hablamos de gestación
subrogada comercial evidentemente pero
no todos los modelos de gestación
subrogada son comerciales creo que es
razonable pensar que hay otros modelos
que son modelos altruistas algunos
altruistas puros otros incluyen una
compensación de lo que vendrían a ser
gastos razonables y por tanto creo que
dirigir el discurso únicamente hacia un
modelo
es de alguna manera falso
mire en varios países como Estados
Unidos como Ucrania o incluso como
Israel la gestación subrogada es
considerada una práctica legal Usted
cree que hay una manera de llevar a cabo
una práctica como esta de una manera
ética y respetuosa con las personas que
gestantes porque por ejemplo podríamos O
tal vez no compararlo con métodos como
la fecundación in vitro
Bueno creo que que la comparación con la
fecundación in vitro es totalmente
desafortunada la fecundación in vitro es
una técnica de reproducción asistida la
gestación por sustitución es una
práctica mucho más compleja puesto que
requiere que una mujer geste para otra
mujer o para una pareja o para un hombre
solo
y siempre requiere de una técnica de
reproducción asistida ya sea esta
fecundación in vitro
inicialmente podía ser también
inseminación artificial etcétera no
Entonces yo creo que la equiparación No
no es no es acertada no dicho esto Bueno
yo creo que depende del modelo en el que
en el que nos basemos reitero lo
anterior no solo hay un modelo comercial
sino que hay otros modelos y los países
que lo regulan algunos de ellos lo
regulan de una forma podríamos decir
ética puesto que exigen por ejemplo
controlar que la gestante lo hace de
forma altruista lo hace con pleno
consentimiento informado Sabiendo a lo
que consciente
evitando la profesionalización de esta
práctica que una mujer lo puede hacer 20
veces en su vida Esto
normalmente está limitado no es posible
entonces hay maneras para para limitar y
sobre todo para regularlo si no lo
regulamos
entran los mercados negros no entonces
regular es una forma de limitar claro
sobre eso le quería preguntar porque se
tiende también a agrupar todas las
formas de reproducción asistida en una
sola y pues no los procesos son
radicalmente diferentes pero más allá de
las personas que están antes porque los
ejemplos que veíamos en el reportaje de
nuestra corresponsal eran de personas
que aspiraban a poder tener paternidades
y que no podían tenerlas en un primer
caso por enfermedad y por un tratamiento
oncológico y en otro primer caso pues
por ser una pareja homosexual pero más
allá de este deseo de paternar uno
tendría que evaluar los derechos humanos
de esos bebés no porque digamos que no
existe el derecho a paternal pero sí
existe el derecho a tener una familia y
esto compete prácticamente a los niños
cómo se controla entonces que esto no se
vuelva como si se ha vuelto en Ucrania
en América Latina y en otros países del
mundo en una práctica meramente
comercial que no solo no está regulada
sino que a todas luces violentas los
derechos de la mujer porque nadie tiene
como controlar nueve meses de gestación
Y cómo están sucediendo Pues dentro de
esta transacción
Bueno creo que aquí hay dos planos
distintos uno sería el plano
internacional Cómo controlar que los
países en los que se practica son países
en los que se respetan los Derechos
Humanos
todos los Derechos Humanos de las
personas implicadas de las mujeres
estantes por supuesto pero también de
los bebés que han nacido o que están en
camino no Y desde otro punto de vista
creo que a nivel interno a nivel
doméstico los estados también pueden
hacer mucho no a nivel internacional me
consta que la conferencia de la haya
está trabajando en unas directrices
comunes y uniformes a nivel de Estados
globalmente pero que todavía no hay
resultados en materia por ejemplo de
adopción internacional existe una
convención Porque no podría existir una
convención en materia de gestación
subrogada no
es una cuestión que se plantea y en la
que digo Se está trabajando desde hace
unos años y pienso También que a nivel
interno los estados
que están exportando el problema entre
entre ellos España deberían también
realizar una reflexión no solo de tipo
jurídico sino ético porque no permitir
que se lleve a cabo en tu país tiene
consecuencias Y es que se está llevando
a cabo en otros y perdemos el control de
lo que está pasando en muchos de estos
países entonces regular es una manera de
poner límites de controlar no y hay
maneras éticas de regular repito Claro
pero si quiere llevar la conversación
incluso a un plano más filosófico y más
digamos en Pos de las luchas feministas
alrededor del mundo en muchos feminismos
rechazan la maternidad subrogada porque
involucran una transacción aunque digan
que es de manera altruista claro lo que
están criticando aquí es que el cuerpo
de la mujer sea utilizado para otro fin
y pues en ese sentido hacemos parte de
una mercancía usted te diría sobre este
tema porque Más allá de que haya un
consentimiento de que haya una
regulación o de que haya digamos lo que
se consideraría un pago justo para estas
mujeres de todas maneras si existe una
instrumentalización del cuerpo de la
mujer que pues es básicamente lo que ha
combatido el feminismo no solo en este
sino en otros frentes de Derechos
Humanos
Sí sí evidentemente es una
reivindicación que me parece muy sensata
entre otras cosas porque solo las
mujeres o las personas gestantes pueden
llevar a cabo este proceso que implica
la gestación subrogada no pero sí que
quiero Añadir que el feminismo como bien
saben es un movimiento que es complejo
Que es plural y que dentro del feminismo
hay posiciones a favor de regular la
gestación subrogada entre otras cosas
porque
de un lado permite disociar maternidad y
mujer es decir no siempre
la mujer tiene que ir asociada a mi
madre a criar a cuidar puede haber otros
modelos no Y la gestación haría posible
uno de estos modelos la gestación por
sustitución no y al mismo tiempo también
desde el feminismo se ensalza la idea
del consentimiento no las mujeres somos
capaces de decidir y con información
podemos decidir sobre gestar para otros
no si se nos explican bien las
condiciones Si sabemos En qué
circunstancias lo estamos llevando a
cabo para quién lo estamos llevando a
cabo y a cambio de qué no Bueno pues
mire aquí lo que hemos tratado de hacer
ese llevar a cabo un debate justo sobre
los argumentos que pueden tener las
personas que buscan maternar de una
manera saludable y las personas que
hacen posible esas maternidades o esas
paternidades así como las personas que
discuten mucho o que hay una violación
de derechos humanos de por medio Yo le
agradezco por ayudarnos a ampliar esos
argumentos y ampliar la discusión en
tendiendo que es un tema que no
solamente es polémico digamos en la
gente de a pie sino dentro de las
propias discusiones feministas Muchas
gracias a usted
muchas gracias buenas tardes a nuestros
televidentes sigan con nosotros en
France 24 nos vemos Próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]